All right, welcome everybody to today's Zoom call.
Today we're gonna talk about some promising cancer solutions
that are on the rise.
Patient asked me about this, so I wanted to address it.
One is this new CAR-T cell therapy,
and so that's what we're gonna talk about first.
CAR-T cell therapy is where they remove your T cells,
they remove your blood, separate out the T cells,
so T cells are part of your immune system killer cells,
and then they adapt the T cells
similar to what is done with the immunotherapy
that is out there like Kutruda,
but they're actually adapting your own T cells
and changing the receptor sites on your own T cells
so that they'll be attracted to that cancer.
So it's a really exciting therapy
and I'm gonna try to share my desktop here
so that I can show you this video of CAR-T cell therapy
from MD Anderson.
So hopefully this will work, so you can listen to this.
This is the immune system that's helped to fight off infections.
T cells can react and kill cancer cells
in the right circumstances.
The problem is that some of the cancers can evade
the immune system.
CAR-T cell therapy is very unique in different
than any other treatment that we've had.
It's a treatment where we take the patient's own T cells
and we modify them in a laboratory
so that they can recognize and react against their cancer.
The patient undergoes a ferrisis,
which is the process of removing the T cells.
We modify them in a laboratory to express receptors
to better recognize cancer.
Those T cells are then expanded and grown to large numbers
and we re-infuse those modified T cells
back into the patients through an IV.
The CAR-T cells that are generated
all have a similar receptor on them
and this receptor recognizes a cancer cell.
Patients can get flu-like symptoms
or neurologic symptoms from the treatment.
Right now, we're giving patients
partisotherapy in the hospital
because their symptoms can become very severe.
We're currently treating childhood and young adults
acute lymphoblastic leukemia.
In addition, we're treating patients
with non-hatch canzum phoma,
particularly diffuse large b-cellum phoma.
MD Anderson researchers are working
to expand application of heart T cells
to other cancers, including solid tumors.
So that is some excited therapy that is on the way,
we hope, and the problem is right now
it's really only been FDA approved
for some childhood leukemias
and certain types of lymphoma.
So it's not available for everyone.
And there's other problems to it.
I wanna address that too.
I was actually gonna do a video on this a few weeks ago
and do a post on this.
So I really get this on Facebook
but then somebody asked the question,
so I thought I'd better do this.
So really what's done with heart T therapy
is that you're collecting the person's own blood,
they're taking the T cells,
they're changing the receptor site on the T cell.
Because remember, one of the problems with fighting cancer
is that cancer cells are your own body cells.
They're not a virus or bacteria
that is an enemy trying to kill your body.
So your immune system isn't supposed
to react to your own cells.
That's what if you don't therapy does too,
is it changes that receptor site on the T cells
as they attack the cancer,
but it's done through a drug.
Heart T therapy is taking out your blood,
changing your T cells, reproducing them in the laboratory,
putting them back in the body
so that they start fighting the body.
Start fighting the cancer.
The problem is is that it will start fighting all cells
and that's what the doctor was alluding to that short video.
And you can get even a worse autoimmune reaction
that you can with a ketruda.
But you can get a good kill of the cancer.
So there's some promising to it.
Problem that they're having with it is the cost.
So an article that I was going to share a few weeks ago
was an article that Medicare came out
and said they're not going to pay for it.
The problem is like this article here,
this is from May 2019.
This Dr. Professor of Medicine at Oregon Health Science University
stated that the cost of care,
the cost of the drug itself is over $475,000
for a year use of this.
And then it could cost a hospital $1.5 million
and that's in an uncomplicated case.
It could be well over $200 or $2 million.
It treats somebody with CAR T cell therapy.
So insurance companies are just balkyred at it
and not approving it.
So it's going to be very difficult for the cost of that care
where going and doing chemotherapy,
even long extended several years of chemotherapy
can still be under a million dollars.
This is going to be well over a million dollars
right off the bat.
And it's looking like they're not going to be able
to get that price down.
Another article from a European paper in England
talked about the same thing.
The price is the real hindered points
so it's not going to be used.
And it's unfortunate that it comes down to cost.
I have no idea what the cost of manufacturer is.
I have no idea if this is a gojean issue
and nothing I have read about it as far as cost
has showed or even alluded to that it is a drug company
gojean issue.
It's just the cost of doing a procedure like this
is so exorbitant.
So that's all I am familiar with.
So there's a lot of information
you can certainly Google search it yourself
about the information of just issues with it.
And then lastly, it's like anything else,
we get really excited about a new type of medication
or a new type of medical therapy like this.
But even at this, you look at the survival rights,
this is the way the cost of the value
of CAR T-cell therapy.
OK, it costs five times more than standard chemotherapy
and a hundred times more than doing an alternative approach.
But then do you get better results?
I mean, you do have to weigh that out.
Are you getting better results for the money?
From a financial perspective, you have to look at this.
I mean, here's just one 75 patients down in this study.
75 patients treated with this type of cell therapy.
And Alice has found an overall remission rate
within three months was 81%.
But how much better is that with lymphoma
than other therapies?
This study did compare that.
The rates of event free survival,
meaning not having a reoccurrence where 73% in six months
in 50% in 12 months.
That means that 50% of the people within a year after treatment
that disease came back.
So to me, that's not the greatest.
So how much better is it than standard chemotherapy?
On some of these cancers that have poor results
with chemotherapy, that maybe this is a viable care option
that I can understand their position of that.
But we certainly get better results
of that with our lymphoma patients.
So we haven't had very many childhood leukemia patients.
But so I understand with diseases
that aren't responding to normal chemotherapy.
And when you only have chemotherapy, radiation,
and surgery in your pocket as a treatment procedure,
these type of new treatment procedures
are very promising and very exciting to them.
They're not quite as excited to me.
But it's worthwhile talking about them.
If somebody can have their life saved
through this process like this,
there are new processes that are coming up.
Well, I'm all on board for that.
So hopefully that helps explain a little bit
of what CAR T cell therapy is.
And while you haven't had it offered to you by your oncologist,
because it just number one isn't available.
And number two, insurance companies will pay for it.
And that's going to take a number of years
to work all that out.
I know one of the patients that acquired about it to me today
was looking, they were talking about Mexico
clinics possibly offering this.
And I don't know if they're just talking about it right now
or they're actually offering it, we'll have to find out.
All right, so I'm going to open it up.
I'm going to mute you also.
You are all unmuted.
So if you have any questions now is the time to chime in,
if you want to talk about what we spoke about
or something completely different.
Here's your opportunity.
Dr. Conner.
OK, go ahead.
Well, I will find those letters.
I said you're talking about the letter
just in general, so I see a bad thing to think about, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
OK, who has a question?
OK, I do, Dr. Conner.
Can you hear me?
I can.
I'm sorry, this is my first time on the Zoom call.
This is Karen Stettel.
I think that the clinic, July 2nd, and you were,
I think you're on vacation, but my question is this.
I had a radical history and had Coriocarcinoma,
which is supposed to be a very aggressive cancer.
And my HCG levels, after my surgery, were 635.
And then they had dropped to 352.
Well, in a matter of one month, they shot up to 12,996.
And I just got the results back yesterday
because I'm having my oncologist check set every month.
My question is, I've been very diligent to do the rough.
I've not missed one time since I've been there.
I'm diligent on my diet and all my protocols.
And I just didn't know if there was something else I need
to be doing, or why it would jump that much.
I just did anything that you have.
I was just wondering.
Sure.
Did you get the email that Michelle sent you?
Oh, I haven't checked.
I haven't checked, guys.
I had her respond to you right away.
So I would want to do, I want to talk to you
because I want to look at any other labs that you had done.
Did you have anything done or any other scans done at all?
Yes, I had a CT scan.
And all that, I just sent you all my paperwork from my oncologist
like two weeks ago when you have everything that I have.
So let's schedule a time for you and I to talk tomorrow.
Perfect.
I can do it at your convenience.
OK, if you want to just call the office either right after this call
or tomorrow morning, schedule a time, we'll get it all onboarded
because I got some ideas for you.
Well, Dr. Conner's thank you so much.
And I will call tomorrow morning.
OK, sounds good.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Dr. Conner's, this is Mary.
Yeah.
The last four or five days, I've been having a lot of aching
in the back of my neck and the back of my head.
And it made it hard for me to be able to move my head
because of stiffness, because of the aching, I guess.
And then last night when I woke up, I could feel in my chest
that it's been sore when I breathe a little bit deeper
than shallow.
It gets a little bit harder.
It gives it hurts.
But anyway, your chest.
Yeah, but I've been doing all the protocol
that I'm supposed to be doing as far as supplements and diet
and the rife every night.
And like, even right now, I'm doing the foot bath.
And I've been doing the things.
I just don't know what else to do with this.
Let's walk through this a little bit.
So paid in the chest that, oh, I haven't had that much
paid in my chest through this.
And paid upon a deep breath indicates a couple of things.
You could have rib involvement, meaning a worst-case scenario
metastasis to a rib.
But then you'd have more pinpoint paid
along that rib most likely.
So it's probably not that.
Next worst-case scenario is slight demotivation.
And that's something you want to jump on right away.
So you need to have a lot of infection.
Can be a big problem.
So I would suggest on your rife program,
in the alphabetical listing, you have several pneumonia
programs.
Can you hear me, Mary?
Yes, I can.
There's several pneumonia programs.
The one I like best is the one that says,
pneumonia blaster.
And we're taking a shot in the dark here.
Well, what if it's not the pneumonia?
Well, so what?
We just want to make sure you don't have a lung infection.
Because it's not uncommon when you have some immune
compromise from cancer that you end up
getting a secondary lung infection in a pneumonia.
And people could die from a pneumonia and not from the cancer.
So run that demotiv blaster.
Also, if you have any herbal sprays,
some people carry an herbal throat spray.
If you have any herbal immune stimulants like echinacea
or garlic, it can be good for that as well.
Or a straggolus can be good for that.
Do you have any of those in your cupboard?
Well, I have garlic, but I don't have a spray of garlic.
You can take it or you can take it orally.
You're not on a blood dinner, are you?
No.
OK, so you can take garlic as a capsule,
or a donation as a capsule if you have that,
or any other immune stimulants as a capsule.
I just don't want you to have a secondary pneumonia
or something like that.
OK.
So do that tonight.
Run that demotiv blaster.
I don't remember.
I think it's only a couple hours long.
Maybe you want to run that a couple of times tonight.
And then if you don't feel like it's any better or you feel
like it's worse, I want you to call me tomorrow morning
and set up a time to talk.
OK.
Thank you.
So don't ignore it.
Stay on it.
Also some essential oils can help if you have thieves
run some essential oils in a diffuser at night.
That can be helpful in your room at night
and make sure you're not getting a breeze on you
or anything like that.
I do have thieves.
I have the essential oil of thieves.
Good.
If you have a diffuser run that in your bedroom tonight.
OK.
Thank you.
You're very welcome.
Any other questions?
Dr. Connors.
This is Janet Kisling.
Can you hear me?
I certainly can.
Well, great.
This is my first time.
I haven't been able to get on and talk at all.
I've tried numerous times.
And so I'm so glad it's working today.
Oh, good.
I have been doing marvelous since I was there five weeks ago.
I had three or four days of feeling
when I got home and that my energy level jumped up.
I just there were so many days.
I almost felt like that I really had cancer
because I felt so good.
And then last Friday, I could feel myself
a little bit of a tinge of not feeling so good.
And I saturday.
I was having pain and my upper arms, my shoulders, some too.
And then I did a coffee enema in the morning.
And when I would lay to my right side,
I could feel like a bubble of gas that popped up into my left side.
And it has been bothering me quite a bit since then.
Where is it exactly if you were?
Well, and so yesterday, I started thinking about it.
And I thought, yeah, almost feels like I have a rib at a place.
And I went to my character and he said,
he thinks it's my floating ribs
on my left side.
So was it on the left side of your body?
Yes.
OK, so a couple possibilities there.
Then you could have strained, you got to remember that
we have the right to have more than one problem at it.
It'd give a time when we always want to do it.
You have a diagnosis of cancer.
You tend to attribute everything to the cancer.
That's not necessarily fair.
You could have strained a rib.
Yes, you could have.
You could have strained the diaphragm there.
You, so doing some like topical pain relief,
like icy hot or something out there,
that would be a first choice.
If you have access to a tens unit, that would be another choice.
Tens unit T-E-N-S.
OK, I don't.
I have a gene.
I tried that yesterday.
Yeah, you could achieve a machine
in a hot move limb for that could be beneficial.
If that aggravated it, that's a sign of something more structural.
If it, so a tens unit is like electrical stem machine for pain.
OK, I don't have that.
They're really inexpensive.
I think we have them on our store.
They're like 35 bucks.
And that is a good thing to use over mosquito skeletal area,
your back, your ribs, to help relieve pain.
What it does is it stimulates in kephalins and endorphins
for pain relief.
But that's going to really work on structural issues.
The third thing that could be going on,
you could have referral paid from a cancer site to that area,
you could have referral paid from your gut to that area.
So how's your digestion better?
If you have normal bowel movements since then?
Yes, yes.
Well, that's the other thing is I've been doing.
So I wasn't doing so well at my doing the,
I've been doing coffee enemas two to three times a week.
But I decided I was going to step up with all of that.
And so I've done the last three days in a row.
I'm wondering I've done that.
I've also got, I was reading in your book
and I really decided to go back to the Budwig program.
I kind of had let that drop.
So I added that a couple of days ago.
So what I guess my question is, I'm having these weird pains,
which I agree with you.
I'm not so sure that it's like,
I'm not so worried about it being cancer,
except for my arms.
I keep wondering about the bones and my upper arms.
That and, but then I'm just going back to what I've had
so many times over is weakness and shakiness.
Which I've had so many times when I'm heavily detoxing.
Okay.
Well, I'm trying to decide would would doing the coffee enemas.
Could I be just doing too much with that cause a problem and then adding the.
I don't know.
Did we already do your genetics?
We didn't get your genetics.
No, no, no, I don't, I haven't heard back from anyone about that.
I would think it would be soon.
Okay, so we did it.
Get it back then.
So what I would say is that you do have the possibility of having a certain gene
where you do not detox caffeine very quickly.
And then if that's true, yeah, you could be having a reaction of the caffeine and the coffee enemas.
So why don't we just take that out stop that.
Stop the bud wig because it could be a reaction to the.
The k seed of the.
The kind of cheese as well.
I was doing the bud wig even before I came out to you, but what I wasn't doing was.
I didn't know about adding the ground flax seed.
And I never did honey in it.
I just did fruit.
Which is another question.
I wondered is it okay for me to do a teaspoon of honey every day.
Cause a teaspoon, you'll be fine.
Yeah.
All right.
And then the ground flax seed.
Those are the two things I had not been doing, but I had been doing the all of the.
The cottage cheese and the oil for months.
And then I stopped for a few weeks after I got back from out there being out there.
I stopped because there were so many things trying to get everything started and do everything and.
Let's stop that again because your body could have gotten used to be the k seed free.
And then you went back on it.
You just had a tummy reaction to it and then you get a reflex pain.
Yeah, I have to say that I've got a lot of gas right now.
I mean, I just feel like I'm really bloated in my ribs or hurting even.
And one more thing I wondered is I ran out of that.
Is it called butane?
BET.
Yeah.
Well, see, that's probably your problem right there.
So I wondered, have it coming.
It's coming.
I ordered it for the store and it should be here tomorrow.
So that's what's going to be your digestive aid for everything going into your stomach.
I had to put up on the Facebook page.
Again, this video that I created with Michelle a few months ago.
How to pull down your height.
Yeah.
So a higher hearty is when your stomach can kind of creep up into the height as the whole.
That is made in higher diaphragm.
And where your esophagus comes down through your stomach.
Down through your through the diaphragm and the stomach is right underneath it.
So that's commonly a problem.
And that can give you symptoms that you just described.
OK.
So I made a video since patients can't always be here to how to pull down your height or hernia on your own.
So I'm looking for right now.
Here it is.
And I will post it right back on Facebook right now.
Awesome.
So that just look at that and try doing that.
And that will hopefully help too.
All right.
So my my main question is I was doing so good.
I mean, I had tons of energy almost too much energy because I hate to admit it.
I wasn't resting like I should have been.
And we were canning and I didn't get as much sleep.
And so I mean, I wasn't resting that much.
I mean, you know, I'm not resting that much.
Not from being like four weeks of tons of energy feeling great.
A little to no pain.
To in a matter of two or three days.
Feeling really bad again.
Is this something where I can where I need to say oh my goodness.
I need to call, and I need to reschedule.
And no, no, no, no, I wouldn't say that.
But it's good to go, huh, what is this?
It's not uncommon at all for a person with cancer to feel great and then feel really
lousy.
That's the entire story of my life.
So I've been reading a little bit of your eye.
I appreciate you so much, Dr. Canners.
And I got on today and started reading some of the posts you had put out about things you're
going through.
It is such.
I'm so sorry that you're having to go through it, but it's such a blessing and I am praying for you.
Oh, well, thank you so much.
Well, and I hope that I'm going through it for a purpose to help you and other people.
So that's that it's that's all worth it.
So.
Yeah.
Thank you for all of this and I'll just continue on.
I wasn't doing I was doing fine with the coffee animals every two to three times a week.
And it wasn't bothering me.
Maybe it's just too much.
It's a combination of probably is a combination of several things, but that's what I'm that's what we're here for.
So don't feel bad about calling and set up at a time to talk or or getting a Facebook page to ask that question of myself or Michelle directly or or getting
on this call and do just what you did.
So that's what it's for.
Thank you.
I always feel like I'm being a father.
So I appreciate answering.
No, you're not.
You're not being about it.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Oh, you're welcome.
Okay.
So another question.
Can you just say a few words to help me reconcile God's sovereignty and my complete belief that he is able to heal.
Good question.
So, okay, so that's understand a couple things first.
Yeah, we all want God to heal our problems.
I want God to heal my cancer as much as you want God to heal your cancer.
Maybe.
But we have to realize that if it wasn't for God's sovereignty, my body wouldn't be functioning right now.
I have 100,000,000,000 cells that have to do 100,000,000 activities each every second in order for me to even sustain life.
So if it wasn't for God's sovereignty right now, I wouldn't be talking to you.
It's only by God's blessing that I have life at all.
So it's if I know we don't want this disease that we want to live to be a hundred or whatever your goals and your dreams are.
But we want to in our our walk of sanctification here on earth, we want to make sure that.
The greatest desire of our heart is to become more and more like his son Jesus and to glorify him by developing a deeper relationship with him.
Even though I want to be healed from my cancer and I want to go out on my boat, which I did only three times this year on my tuneboat.
And I want to go do stuff with my wife and my kids and my grandkids.
Those are all wonderful blessings.
Those are all mercies from God.
And I need to make sure I stay focused on that fact that those are mercies from God and that those aren't my idols in my life.
Those are blessings because of God's mercy.
And that helps me at least keep an understanding that the that my desires more than anything else have to align with what his desires are.
And I just made mention to you just a second ago that I would gladly have this cancer and struggle with it.
If it can bring glory to God by blessing somebody else, if that's how God wants to use me is for me to go through suffering so that I can be a blessing because of that.
That I would rather bring glory to God and spend eternity with him.
Then to live to be a hundred and fulfill my earthly self centered dreams here on earth.
And that that desire in itself doesn't make me a holier person that desire in itself only comes from the mercies of God.
So I'm saying is from a selfish perspective, we're all narcissists from a humanly perspective, we're all sinners.
That's all we do is think of ourselves, but if it wasn't for the grace of God, we would all be like son of Gamora.
The point is is that the only way that I can bring God glory is to ask him for his mercies and ask him for his desires in my heart.
So this is hard to doctorate to go on and explain, but if I could just encourage everybody, whether you have cancer or not to just your prayer to be, yeah, I pray that my cancer goes away.
But more and much more than that, do I pray that I can bring glory to God today and that I can take joy in the mercies that he shows me and the grace that he shows me today.
And then it's not so important that my cancer goes away.
It's more important that I bring glory today.
And because I'm going to spend eternity somewhere, I want to spend eternity getting to know my Heavenly Father more and more and more and more every single day.
And I'd gladly suffer on this earth to help someone else accomplish that same purpose.
So my prayer is yes, I pray for you guys that your cancer goes away, that you can live a long and healthy life, but I pray for your maturity, I pray that you learn from this disease, I pray that you grow through this disease.
I pray that your sanctifying walk here on earth through this disease brings you to the point of you being able to be thankful for your cancer because it changed you and molded you and shaped you into a different person and ultimately brought you closer to him.
Sorry to get on the preaching for there, but I just thank you for the talk today and please send your questions if you have questions that you don't want to speak out loud.
Send them to the email with address to zoom question in the in the email, so we make sure that we see it and we'll try to address them and I just ask that God bless you guys and that he keeps your mind focused on his ultimate purpose for you that you can bring him more glory today than yesterday.
Alright, bye bye you guys.
Thank you.
You're welcome. Love you all.
Love you too. God bless you.
Thank you.